con aplausos frente al congreso fue
recibido el anuncio de la legalización
de la eutanasia en españa la aprobación
de la ley que se dio con 202 votos a
favor 141 en contra y 2 abstenciones
permitirá que dentro de tres meses
cuando entre en vigor la legalización
del territorio español se convierta en
el séptimo de reconocer este derecho
tras bélgica países bajos nueva zelanda
luxemburgo canadá y colómbia es un día
importante para toda la ciudadanía
porque avanzamos hacia una sociedad más
humana y más justa pero sobre todo es un
día importante para aquellas personas
que se encuentran en una situación de
grave padecimiento además de hoy no sólo
empezamos a legalizar la eutanasia y de
conquistar un derecho hoy también
emprendemos el camino para que este
derecho esté incluido como una
prestación más en la cartera de
servicios del sistema nacional de salud
mejorando de este modo nuestra capacidad
asistencial ante la aprobación nos
hicieron esperar las reacciones tanto a
favor como en contra
me siento feliz me siento tranquila
porque tenía un pacto con mi esposo y le
dije que seguiría luchando por esto
justo después de su muerte y hoy lo
logramos hoy es el día de la victoria lo
hicimos para que sea un día muy feliz
pues hoy es un día triste porque hoy
venimos aquí a reclamar nuestro derecho
a la vida donde el derecho fundamental a
la vida y a reclamar nuestro derecho a
la libertad también porque con esta ley
no se deja ninguna libertad a los que
sufren y se les empuja a tomar la
solución más rápida que es la muerte
quienes podrán solicitar la eutanasia
serán los mayores de edad que presenten
una enfermedad grave o incurable que les
genere sufrimiento psicológico o físico
constante e intolerable según lo
aprobado el solicitante deberá confirmar
varias veces el deseo de seguir adelante
con el proceso y podrá desistir en
cualquier momento